chair of the house ways and means
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency
declared by the government as a result
of covert 19 pandemic
and according to the house rule 67 the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 20 202004
this public bodies lots of ours to meet
electronically
and hopefully this will get over soon
this is a work session in revenues
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporariously to this
meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order and confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporariously
during the meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaries
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zone platform
or by telephone all necessary access
information has been made available on
the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the notice for this meeting complies
with the house rules
and irsa 91a anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should call 271
or email hcs lake.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned
and rescheduled i want to introduce the
staff that are on the meeting
assisting us jennifer iv the committee
researcher
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting should be done
by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking roll
call attendance
when each member states that president
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room would you
join this meeting which is required
under the right to know law
representative bernstein you want to
take a roll call of attendance
thank you mr chair and good morning to
you and good morning to everyone
i'd like to welcome our guests to ways
and means thank you for joining us this
morning
uh it's may 19th 20 21 a.m we'll begin
roll call with representative patrick
abrami
yes i'm here in my home in stratham my
wife is in the house
representative mary griffin
representative jordan hollery
home hudson wife is in the house
someplace
representative russell elbert allman
hudson with the six cats
representative ducette your clerk is
alan berstein i'm at my home in
beautiful nottingham new hampshire
in my home office by myself
representative robert elliott
representing elliott you muted you
pushed the right button
okay i'm here can you hear me
alan i want that tie when you're done
with it too
i hear you loud and clear it's good to
see you
representative john cena
representative herschel nunes good
morning mr clerk i'm here in pelham new
hampshire home alone representative tim
baxter
thank you mr clerk i'm home alone on
this beautiful day
representative walters pillsbury good
morning i'm home in charlestown with my
wife and son
floating in the house good morning
representative paul
tudor mr clerk i'm
back in the cellar in northwood wife and
grandkids are upstairs
i hope they let you out soon
representative susan almi
good morning home alone in lebanon
representative richard ames
yeah i'm here in jeffrey in my home
office alone
representative thomas southworth here in
dover
alone representative dennis maloy
here greenland uh alone the honorable
representative thomas c
schaumburg uh thank you representative
bernstein of revolutionary lane
nottingham i am aaron wilmet
by myself good morning representative
edith tucker
i'm here in randolph alone
a special good morning to representative
jenny gomarlo the birthday girl
i am in swansea alone
at the moment happy birthday
she's only 39.
and it's tomorrow not today
representative tom lofman
representative amanda gourd good morning
i am present and alone
representative mary hacken phillips good
morning i am present and alone as well
representative james murphy good morning
i'm alone in my home in hanover thank
you
our chair representative norman major
good morning i'm
home in my office in pasto and my wife
is in the house
mr chair there are 20 members present
four members are unable to join us right
now
the agenda for this morning is we're
going to start with the
members of the chamber of commerce who
will be joining us to talk about
their experience with the ppp loans
then we were scheduled to have
emily block talk to us
relative to the rules and regulations
and
how we can uh handle the
american recovery funds the 1.9 million
dollars that
we just billion trillion dollars that we
distributed
across the united states um but
she called this morning and said she had
to meet with treasury
but she will be joining us at noontime
so we're going to go longer
into the noon hour but i think everybody
but the second thing that we're going to
be doing is the dra
is going to explain the fiscal
impact timing of senate bill 3
and that's information was sent to the
members of the committee
along with the table that they will be
explaining that and
answering other questions relative to
[Music]
so we will start
with the members of the chamber of
commerce
and from what i see right now we have
tracy hutchins from the upper valley
chamber of commerce
wendy hunt from the greater nashua
and donna mars from the salem chamber of
commerce
oh i'm sorry valerie roshan also just
joined from portsmouth
okay valerie welcome aboard and
they are going to talk to us about
their experience with the ppp loans
and then we'll be able to ask them
questions
uh let me first of all
there was a few questions that were sent
to them
because are there
businesses out there that got the ppp
loan grant and are earning enough profit
now including
the ppp to have to pay
vpt and the businesses realize
grants are taxable by by the business
profits tax in new hampshire
when they took the money those are two
of the questions
sure thank you representative major and
and
thank you uh committee for uh having us
as well i corresponded previously with
representative
almi and representative murphy on this
issue
both had contacted me and asked me those
two questions
and my answer to them was
one talking about if any of the
businesses
did better than they expected uh
from 2020 versus their 2019 revenues
the the answer is yes we and i i think
my chamber colleagues will
also confirm that is it it depends very
much
on what the type of business it was
uh you know some of our industries
did have a good year in 2020
businesses that had anything to do with
home
improvement with outdoor recreation
as people were confined to their homes
and were
looking for things to do or they wanted
to fix up their homes
those businesses had a fairly good year
and so the answer to that question is
yes there
are some businesses who could pay
the bpt without any issue however
we also had numerous businesses
that were struggling and those are the
industries that many of you have already
heard of
restaurants have had a very difficult
year
even though they were able to do outdoor
dining or
many of them were able to do outdoor
dining in many cases that was not able
to replace
what their normal business operations
were
some of them were able to pivot to take
out however
takeout again does not replace
having people come in sit down in a
dining room
and then you know decide to get dessert
when
maybe they didn't order dessert versus
takeout so their revenues were down
significantly
um hotels and lodging properties had an
extremely difficult year we had other
businesses that
were shut down for a significant amount
of time and that were never able to
catch up some of our retail businesses
experience that so so the answer is it's
very much a mixed bag
in terms of who did well and who did not
well
the other question that you asked was
did businesses realize that they would
have to pay
tax when they accepted the ppp
uh loan and my
my answer and i and i hope my chamber
colleagues will jump in as well
my businesses and the ones that i've
talked to for the most part
that was not what they were concerned
about at the time that they accepted the
ppp
the ppp program was put out
by congress as a relief program
and at the time that the ppp was first
introduced things were changing very
very rapidly
you know we are sitting here 14 months
away
from when we first shut down those first
few weeks have shut down
things were just changing so rapidly
businesses
all of a sudden had no revenue coming in
[Music]
and had no idea if or when they would be
able to reopen
and the ppp was their lifeline it was
their lifeline to
try to hang on to their employees or to
keep their employees
to try to keep their businesses you know
for some of our business people
everything that they have including
their home
is tied up into their business
one example is i have a restaurant group
that is located in hanover
and on the lebanon border and
that restaurant group when the shutdown
happened they gave away
100 000 in food
they spent three days packaging up the
food they gave it to their 150 employees
that they
just furloughed and then they gave the
rest of it to
a local food shelter so for them the ppp
was a way to hang on to some of their
staff
and when they were able to reopen
they had to use some of those ppp funds
to rebuy
that hundred thousand dollars of
perishable food that they had to let go
when the shutdown occurred so you know
in terms of whether they thought they
were going to be taxed on that program
i really don't think it entered their
mind they they were looking
it was survival it was about survival
and for many of our businesses
it was so i would like to let my chamber
colleagues jump in
at this point as well wendy do you want
to go
sure um i'd like to thank the committee
for um hearing us today
i think that sorry my voice um
i took a little different approach in
answering your questions
the first one what were businesses
expect exp what was their
expectation when they applied for the
ppp loan meaning did they expect to have
to pay taxes on it
um i've been hearing from our members
that
they are definitely not back up to
operating order
but i wanted to um the way i approached
it was i
i talked to the source of the money and
to
a cpa and to a financial advisor so the
first person i talked to was a
commercial lender
and i asked who's a chamber member i
said
um i asked her if she'd done the ppp
loans and she said she'd done a lot of
them
and she said in round one not one single
client and she did hundreds of these
loans
asked the question will i have to pay
taxes on this
her words this money was a lifeline they
were out of money
and they were just trying to stay afloat
that was
really compelling to me the next person
i talked to was a cpa who has many small
businesses as clients also a chamber
member
he said most businesses intuitively
intuitively looked at this as a lifeline
if the ppp funds were coming out of
federal funds most businesses
did not stop to think about tax
ramifications ramifications on the state
level in new hampshire
the last person i talked to that chamber
member was a financial advisor
and she said to many small business
owners they
they told her that they had to dip into
their personal savings
and taken out second mortgages just to
try to keep their businesses afloat
so even with the ppp loans they're still
not back to where they should be
all of them and our and our chamber
members
seem to really um want me to impress
upon you that this was a pandemic
we did not see this coming it's probably
once in a lifetime for many of us
they did what they had to do to keep
their businesses alive
um they tried to keep employees and do
they tried to do all the right things
so i do understand this committee's
concern about not you know the tax
revenue
that we're going to lose as a state if
you support this
but i can tell you our businesses have
not recovered um
if you liken this to the ppp really
just put our um our businesses back
out from the hospital because they were
on life support and one of my members
say we were in life support and the ppp
funds
got us back out and going
if they have to take pay taxes they're
going to be back in the emergency room
um many other members told me that
while they have tried to get back up to
full operations they've been unable to
because um of the lack of workforce so
even those that have tried to get back
you know back to pre-pamdemic have been
unable to so i'd like you to factor that
in
that they're not where they need to be
so
the first question of did they expect to
have to pay taxes
not a single one of them entered their
minds because they were
on absolute their last leg
um also the fact that our businesses are
not back up
i can tell you my office is on main
street in nashua
it's still very quiet most restaurants
are not open during the day
at all for lunch which i find highly
unusual
um compared to the way it used to be and
that means if people aren't coming down
to eat the restaurants they're not going
to the shops either so
um i think the final thing i would say
is most businesses saw this as a part of
a federal
quote-unquote rescue plan it wasn't
perfect
but it did in fact save many businesses
our net our new hampshire
businesses needed rescuing and these
funds helped them
so i would urge you to please support um
sp3
i'm willing to go who goes next
uh i'd like to don morris from the
greater salem chamber of commerce and
um a lot of this you guys nailed it i
think um
between what tracy had to say and wendy
had to say uh again the two the two
questions
uh how are businesses doing and can they
pay that um
i don't necessarily agree with the
fundamental
premise of that question um given the
spirit in which these funds were
given a rescue spirit but um it's been
very polarized
in um in the industries uh people are
either having great years
or horrible years and there's very
little in between
um so yes some can pay and some
probably are not going to be able to
even as tracy had said earlier
but i think you need to it needs to be
realized that
um people had to those that are having
the great year
they are the you know the the industries
that had to pivot or because of the
pandemic they're having a great year
whether the people are home so
that they have a company that you know
trips people out so that they can work
remotely or their
home improvements because people are
there or they've switched their
uh
shampoo industry to make hand sanitizer
those are not going to as the pandemic
subsides be sustained in that they're
going to go back to so even though
they're having a great year
it's because they pivoted and adjusted
to have their business survive and
certainly ppp helped that
um and then there's the ones where they
were
forcibly shut down and tried to and use
this money to
survive and keep their employees
again most of this has been said and
it's been said well but i would like to
highlight the fact that
some of those businesses doing well
aren't that necessarily you can't
project that out
and some of them doing poorly hopefully
they're getting back up and running so
it's a longer lens
of this i'd like to highlight the fact
that it was relief money the spirit of
that relief money
and you're seeing i believe it's up to
um 40 other
states are not taxing this money the
feds aren't taxing this money
um and i also spoke with a couple of
cpas that are members to talk to them
about what the individual businesses
are seeing um did they expect to pay
this back
absolutely not um it was survival things
were changing daily
all that's been mentioned before there
was one other things i wanted to um
what oh and even the the fact that
you go 14 months back we were talking
about a virus that we thought could live
on surfaces for days on
end so um that money to keep their
employees
if that wasn't there to keep them they
would
have probably been desperate enough to
go out and try and do some type of work
i mean it
it actually helped contain the pandemic
as well
so i think that's something that is
getting kind of lost in here too
that this was a health crisis we were
learning every day
and um the businesses were trying to
survive and
the spirit of this money was to to um
to help shut down the spread of the
pandemic as well as keep people
in business and keep employees um able
to pay their bills as well
uh no no i think everything's pretty
much been covered i reserve the right to
chime in again
as things come to my mind valerie you
want to take it away
thank you um i i just need to echo
everything that tracy
and wendy and donna have said but we'll
we'll add two more um
just just little pieces to add here and
but first i do want to thank you all for
actually listening for inviting us and
for actually
listening um it doesn't always happen
and
i appreciate that you folks have been
willing to do that so thank you for that
one of the smaller businesses that i
spoke with that shut down
and actually had to hibernate over the
winter
said that there's no way that he is
going to be in a position to pay that
tax
tax because he's lost so much money he's
not going to be taxed
he's not he's not going to have to pay
any tax because
he spent all that money on surviving as
the others have said
so um and he's still not back up he's
still
in a he's a small restaurant and
he still can't go to capacity and
and so for him it's a it's sort of a
non-issue he's not going to have to pay
the tax because his expenses have
outweighed his income
for a a larger restaurant that i've i
spent some time with
it really is about recovery that
they don't have the staff they simply do
not have the staff
to either a open up seven days a week to
make the money that they need to make
um or b um
bring in the functions the level of
functions and and and you know this was
happening before combat this is not
alcohol but
um we've been we've been struggling with
workforce particularly in the
hospitality businesses for a long time
for a few years
so now they they you can't bring groups
back those groups that you can bring
back
you can only bring back if you have the
staff to work them
and you don't have the staff to work
them and to work the restaurants so
they are not digging out of the hole as
i think somebody's already said they're
just not digging out of the hole so
did they expect to pay the tax no they
did not it was a lifeline
are they able to pay the tax now are
they able to come up with the money to
pay the tax now
no because they cannot make the revenue
that they need to make in order to pay
those taxes
so um you know as as as
as one of them said to me i used that
money to pay the bills
that's what i used it for i didn't put
in the bank i didn't put it aside for
tax
you know i didn't i didn't pocket it i
paid my employees and i paid my bills
so i have no i you know so
i'm just confirming what others have
already said um that these
these folks their backs are against the
wall and so this is sort of adding um
insult to injury by asking them at this
point to now
um pay the tax so thank you for
listening to us
thank you would you take questions
within your area nashua
upper valley et cetera
i you aware of any
businesses that wanted to get
a ppp loan that was not able to get
pp loan and if so why weren't they able
i'll go first we i did have some
businesses that
investigated uh applying for the ppp
loans and and had a couple actually that
took the loan and then paid it
immediately back
and decided not to stay with it and the
reason for that
was the the sba was changing things very
very rapidly
there was a there was a lot of changing
of
the program and the rules of it
you may recall that it started out
at 60 percent had to go towards
employees but for some of our businesses
like restaurants they they had already
furloughed their employees because they
were literally shut down you know they
were
not in operation and so
and there were very there were competing
programs at the time
so the sba when the ppp was first
introduced it was meant that
businesses would retain their employees
but then there were also other relief
programs so it really made more sense
for the employees to go on
unemployment because there was
additional unemployment benefits
that made it difficult for some of the
businesses to retain their staff and and
also they were completely shut down as
well
so it was so confusing for some
businesses they started off
applying for ppp and then gave it back
because they were not
certain that they were going to meet the
criteria
and then of course in a later iteration
of the ppp
it was changed so then i think it was 75
percent
of your um loan had to go
towards for salaries and
and wages but then you could also use it
for
other incidentals as well so it
it was it was a difficult time the
program was changing
uh with what i think three iterations of
the ppp program
so there were times that the businesses
i don't think they fully trusted the
program sometimes
so we did have some that had it and then
gave it right back
we had others that applied and for
whatever reason
were denied it was just
until things smoothed out i think in the
third iteration
it was difficult for businesses to
really keep up and
keep abreast as to what the expectations
were
if i may ask those that were denied
it was was there a
particular reason why they were tonight
wendy you had your hand raised do you
want to i wasn't i
i don't know about that if you want to
go ahead and take that one i was going
yeah i i can't really say i think it
depends you know for some
it was dealing with the banks and it
depended on
you know whatever particular
you know circumstances i mean every
application
since they were going through an sba
lender was a little bit varied and a
okay thank you so an answer to the
original
question um the members that i know that
did not apply for pvp
were new businesses they did not meet
the criteria to
apply initially for ppp if in fact they
lasted long enough which many did not
they went out of business
um i know one business that i was a
member of mine that not only they go out
of business they got a divorce over it
another
fallout from the pandemic but the
companies that were new
that finally um they changed the
criteria earlier this year
and they were able to file for the
second round um
i can tell you whatever money they got
for the second round was not very much
and in fact they have been on life
support this entire year
the other thing i'd like to point out in
piggybacking on tracy's comments were
um others that could not that could not
file for the ppp loans
i think they just got so frustrated um
if you didn't have a relationship with a
commercial banker
good luck trying to get them to fill out
the application for you
um i can tell you speaking as a
non-profit we are not a
um we are we are a for-profit we're a
non-profit
but we're a 501c6 so all chambers are
basically small businesses
and it was very frustrating the first
round that we were not eligible as 501
c6s
we were scrambling ourselves um so i
liken myself to a small business
it was stressful it was hard to keep
staff and it was
hard to regroup but we were able to do
it um so i hope
valerie you're checking your head you
well i was i was glad that wendy brought
that up we are c6's and we were not
eligible we have been
made eligible in the next in this most
recent round and so
we did receive the ppp funding
um for the second round but
honestly had that not changed had that
status not
changed we would be in a whole lot of
trouble right now so
um i i as wendy said we're small
businesses as well we weren't eligible
and those lifelines have been
absolutely critical to our our
continuation here so
uh i i don't know what other i am not
aware of other
businesses to answer directly for
non-c6s
um some of them just just chose not to
go through the hassle i know that but
otherwise i
i can't answer it for other businesses
thank you um representative romney
followed by representative nunes
and tucker representative thank you
mr i have two uh specific questions
uh first one tracy uh i just want to
make sure we're defining our terms
revenue versus profit so when you say
that some businesses revenue is up
uh other business revenue is down uh
that's revenue but net profit
the profit though would you with the
same the same as
true for profits as well as just gross
revenue
in some cases yes i mean we i have had
some members that said to me that they
that 2020 was actually a a pretty good
year for them and
and was a profitable year again those
are very
industry specific businesses
um you know some of my retail businesses
they
saw a little bump in the fall um even
though we were not supposed to have
visitors in the state we did
and you know we had visitors coming that
were hiking
and doing outdoor activities and in some
cases some of my retail businesses
did see a bump up in business
however they had been down you know from
march until september
you know 30 40 50 percent
if not more so
their revenues went up but did they
overall profit i would say no
they did not donna you want to comment
uh yeah i i was talking with again some
of our cpa members and and
you you great great commenting question
um because for example a couple of our
members
members are um car dealers where they're
in
you know if the price of their product
is large and it goes up it may it may
show that like the revenues are up but
if their expenses are up as well
their profits aren't so it needs to be
looked at on all dimensions not just the
revenue dimension
and uh i think that is an excellent
point i know that that's been coming up
with the whole
main street part um but
um ppp i i also want to go back to a
little bit of um
i wanted to chime in on the whole that
we are 501 c 6's
uh never mind i don't i won't go
backwards
but um the ppp has been used for what
you know and it's not it's not 100
it's a percentage to help with rent
and salaries and things like that so
being aware of revenue versus profit is
super important have the follow-up
mr chair follow-up which is really a
second question i
appreciate it so uh valerie you you
mentioned uh
needing the money to find staff so the
good news is that
governor sununu is doing away with the
that the feds want to give but then he's
converted that
per i saw the news story this morning uh
he's converted that to
thousand dollar bonuses for
if someone uh gets a job
that's unemployed currently thousand
dollar bonus from
from the state of new hampshire using
federal money by the way
uh i forget the exact number but i think
it covers 10 000 people or something
there's enough money in there for 10 000
people and i guess you got to be in the
job for six weeks is what what the news
story said
now interestingly enough i had a
conversation with
one of the founders of aroma joe's i
don't know if you have a roman joe's in
your various
locations and his his comment to me was
you know that if we tax the the
the forgiveness revenue just
that money i can use i could you know if
we don't tax that
that he can use that money to give
bonuses to because he's a he's a he's a
restaurant guy i mean he's a
coffee shop kind of guy and they they
having so much trouble finding people
that he he was going to use some of the
money
instead to to provide bonuses uh signing
bonuses so
can you can you four of you just chime
in and to where your businesses are
because that's the biggest problem we
have it's finding employees and we have
35 000 people on unemployment
so we kind of incentivized these 35 000
people to want to be in the workforce
again so
does anybody want to chime in on that
yeah thank you for asking
representative abrami um
i have i applaud the governor for to
fight for
creating some incentives for hiring on
staff
i will tell you that six weeks is not
going to get us through the summer so if
they stay for six weeks and get their
thousand dollars
they could then quit so that's that's
not going to get us very far and if you
are of the mindset that you're not
working
because you get your 300 a week you
might also be in the mindset to stay for
six weeks and leave
but more importantly i think we need to
understand that
there are a lot of other issues that are
causing people and not going back to
work
number one being child care um kids are
not all back in school
they they they parents are home because
they don't have child care and there's a
disproportionate number of women by the
way
who are not working because they're the
primary caregivers and so they're home
they're also the primary caregivers for
their parents or those who are who have
been sick with cohen
so there are family issues there and
there's also a number of people who are
not yet comfortable
coming back in particularly front line
jobs there are not enough people
vaccinated yet
that this frontline staff is willing to
come back and take that risk and until
more people are vaccinated
they're holding back and saying no i
really i really do not feel comfortable
coming back in and putting myself and my
elderly parents
or my children at risk at risk because
i'm putting myself at risk so there are
a number of other i i think
more more compelling reasons like
why people are not coming back
so the the 300
supplement for some certainly hopefully
will will
uh and and the incentives will hopefully
bring them back
um the the other thing is and i think
that that donald just or somebody just
touched on this
is the opportunity the requirement
now by restaurants competitively
to pay higher wages this was not in the
plan
this is not part of their budget this
was not something that they expected
but they do have to do this we we had an
incident this week
where one of our small pubs he just he
like
opened in like like december
19. so this poor young man
has been doing everything possible to
stay alive
and he just posted
on social media that he was looking for
staff and he was willing to pay them
something like 13
an hour and he was eviscerated on social
because he wasn't paying enough
now this is for weight staff wait staff
makes
a fair amount of money in portsmouth
with tips with gratuities so
this poor guy is trying to do the right
thing he's trying to raise
from two dollars to thirteen dollars and
and uh he needs first of all he's been
told it's not enough
um secondly uh he needs the business in
order to be able it's
sort of this whole chicken egg thing i
need the staff to be able to serve the
customers i need the customers to come
to come in to pay the staff so there's a
real chicken egg thing happening right
now which is causing a whole lot of
stress
for particularly our hospitality
businesses hopefully that answered your
question
yeah thank you keller and i just can i
just make a quick comment
so when i talked to you know my initial
comments
i i was talking about this inability to
find workers
as part of the reasons that our
businesses not have businesses have not
recovered
definitely in the restaurant industry
but even you know trying to find
you know the employees for roman joes
and
as representative um abrami said that
aroma jones actually is a drive-through
so if he can't find them
you know people to to do the
drive-through the restaurants that need
servers and dishwashers and everything
else they're
they're just not back up to where they
need to be
um they use that ppp money to pay the
wages to pay the rent
you know they had to spend it on certain
amount of money as one of my colleagues
said
they weren't putting in the bank and
sitting on it they didn't add on to
their houses they didn't do anything fun
with it
they were just trying to survive so if
we're talking about the workforce
shortage
i think the important point is it is it
definitely exists
it's not it's terrible right now um i
applaud the governor's um moves on
you know no longer providing the extra
a month and the thousand signing bonus
but but i just impressed upon you that
that is this is part of the reason that
the businesses have not recovered
thank you everybody um we have one two
three
four five six more to ask questions so
we're gonna keep it to two questions
maximum
so represented
nunes followed by tougher aim spellsbury
southwest
thank you mr chairman and i want to
thank all of you for joining us today
getting the information
in from you from the people who work in
the towns
that you guys help represent in a
business sense
this is information that we don't get
all the time i i want to shift back just
a little bit
to ask a question about your members and
businesses
are there are is there any population of
them
who took the loan but are having
issues at this point qualifying for the
forgiveness
or do not qualify for the goodness
because i think part of what we're
trying to understand
is is there going to be taxable
um uh on any of this at all
and do we need to just forgive all of it
that's two different questions because
there are guidelines that were given out
we've talked about this already the
guidelines that were given out for 60
or 75 percent has to be applied to a
certain amount
i know small businesses in town that
took the loan
and said well we took the loan but we're
having problems
meeting the guidelines were the
guidelines too stringent or
or do you have any reports about any of
i'll i'll chime in i have not heard
most of my again for the people i've
talked to
qualified for the forgiveness i have not
heard a lot of issues not
qualifying for forgiveness yeah i i
would say the same
most of our businesses that have taken
the loan have
have uh qualified for the forgiveness
i i can tell you i have had businesses
that
took the loan and then of course they
also applied for the main street relief
funds and i've had some businesses that
then came back to me afterwards and said
we're we're still not making it is there
anything else i can apply for
okay i concur i haven't heard of anyone
that applied for forgiveness that
what wasn't granted it thank you very
much
thank you uh representative ames
followed by rep
spillsbury okay thank you
and thank you all for joining us and
providing us with this information
we have experienced as you may have
observed
a spike in our business profit
tax revenue um
[Music]
and we're trying to understand
what why it derives mostly from
a combination of uh money paid
to as part of getting an extension on
the filing
filing deadline for a return and also
money paid on
estimates one theory is that a good
part of it is
represents payment of tax
on ppp loans no proof of that but that's
one of the
thoughts um and there are some
indicators that suggest that
that's happened in some cases so my
question to you is whether
um you have uh any knowledge of some
businesses um
[Music]
paying bbt tax
on the um the ppp loan that they've
received
perhaps with the hope that they'll get a
refund later on
but nonetheless going ahead and making
that payment
so i specifically asked um a cpa that's
on my board
this exact question um because i i
understood there were concerns with this
committee about
the taxes that had been paid and the
nightmare of the dra
dra having to refund it that would come
to come to fruition
and he said without exception um they
just paid them
in hopes that it would be refunded
um i don't think any of them
were thinking that far ahead to be
honest um if they were
so that was for the 2020 taxes if they
were forgiven last year like for example
ours he didn't apply for until this year
so it wouldn't impact us
um but he seemed to think that um i
asked him you know
what you know how tough that would be
for the dra to refund and he said they
would just have to come up with some
regulations and refund it
um and i believe that's what most of the
cpas were advising their clients
according to the cpa i talked to that
they said go ahead and pay them and we
could file for a refund
an amended tax return with the state and
then a refund
and if i may chime into uh so i i spoke
with uh two
cpas that each had over you know 100
clients each that had
done ppp and there's a significant
frustration
with this as well this was introduced
supposed to be some fast-track
legislation
and um the senate voted
unanimously in favor back in march and
uh to seek
most of the cpa community was was
waiting and waiting and waiting and
filing for extensions to find out if
this it would not would or would not be
taxable
and um they ended up just having to file
as if it
was and then cross their fingers that'll
be in reverse reimbursed and that the
committee
will recognize the spirit in which these
funds were provided in the middle of a
pandemic as a rescue package
and for specific things which the
businesses then use them for
so there there's a little frustration
there too as well i don't know if any
other chamber people got
an earful from their uh accountants who
are usually already stressed out
valerie do you have anything to add to
that
i i do not i think that uh wendy and and
donna
have spoken well about that i
i i keep going back to the fact that
this is a this is a rescue package
this this is what allowed these people
they paid people
when they were closed so they and and
quite frankly they felt like they were
throwing the money throwing money away
because they had to close they didn't
have staff they still paid them with the
ppp money
they felt like they were throwing money
away and now we're going to tax them
so i i'm struggling
with with the fact that this was
intended
for good and and i and i totally doubt
that the state
um is concerned about losing was it
200.2 million
uh that i think you've calculated i i
totally get that
but taking it from the folks who are
still
trying desperately to get back on track
thank you okay representative spillsbury
uh yes thank you mr chairman i i
appreciate uh
all four of you for being here because
you're giving us
uh illustrations of things that fade in
our minds
the intensity the uncertainty the
unknown
no sense of how deep it would go
whether they'd have to close completely
all these things
i think we do need to be reminded of and
i have an enormous amount of sympathy
for the businesses
that struggled without
perhaps an option that they could pin it
to
um so it was mentioned before that
that it's very polarized that there are
skewed results
that some businesses did well in other
businesses
may never recover so here's my question
in sb3 we're really dealing only with
those businesses
that did generate a profit
those that closed
not
sb3 available and
ironically to the extent that sb3
will benefit businesses it will benefit
them
in proportion to how well they did
those that did really well will benefit
really well
if i'm sitting here perplexed and
wondering
how sp3 is going to help those most in
need
i'm wondering whether any of you have
considered
suggestions or thoughts that the ways
and means committee might take under
advisement
to better target the businesses that
representative i i'm not sure i
understand
the question so i i expected you to end
that question with um how we would
target those businesses
who actually could pay the tax so i'm
i'm not sure that i understand
the question but um
i i will say that you know in the
in the restaurant revitalization fund
the rrf
fund the calculations
are are really based on the revenue that
you generated that wasn't part of a
grant
and just speaking for the chamber and we
get grants
jpp grants joint promotional program
grants from the
state travel and tourism department
if i had to pay taxes on those grants
they're not loans they're grants if i
had to pay taxes on those grants
as a non-profit i probably wouldn't be
able to take them
or i'd have to minimize what i take
because i can't i can't risk
having to pay those taxes so and i
wonder how many of our businesses feel
that way
so i wonder maybe others
are not confused by the question but i
think i am so
i'd like to just sharpen the question
because uh
i think you're addressing something
because i am sympathetic with those
businesses that struggled and failed to
make a profit
i'm wondering how we would do something
that helped
carried the burden and took the pain
most from the pandemic
rather than to give a tax benefit to
well that's an interesting oh sorry
donna go ahead
i i just think some of that is being
done beyond this i think on the
key part in that uh i think valerie
nailed it there's there's so many things
that that overlap here
with workers and child care and we're
seeing some of that we're seeing
uh you know the governor not
get rid of the three hundred dollars
that was a big complaint the six hundred
dollars trying to get employees
back and they were earning more by not
working
but then there's the whole so that it's
happening in other arenas
with with child care vouchers and
incentives to get people back to work
and taking away incentives to for people
not to work
um so i think those are the things that
are that are gonna
help those that have struggled most but
it's an interesting question i'll think
on it while uh wendy talks too i don't
know if there's something more creative
that we can do as well
um child care vouchers is interesting
i well in answering that particular
question
so i'm hearing right is you're very
concerned about the ones that are barely
hanging on
but on the other hand you don't want to
um
you know if a company did well you don't
want them to have
and had had a great year like i could
tell little grocery stores around us
they were the only thing open for food
um so what you're saying is that the
ones that did really well that probably
had their best year ever
you have a hard time you know having
them not pay taxes
but if you look at it another way the
ones that did really well
they're the ones that pivoted they
changed their business model
so i i see what you're saying it's a lot
of revenue
but i don't see how you can parse it out
i don't think there were that many
corporations or companies or small
businesses
that did have their best year ever ever
i think that's a very small number of
businesses
um and i don't see how you can split it
out
um but i do i do see your point that
they're being they've already had the
best year ever and here we're going to
reward them more
by not taxing them on on any of that but
i just think it's a it's there aren't
that many cases
and from my broad reach of my members
are go from a one-person shop up to some
of the biggest companies
in the country um so i would just keep
that in mind i don't know how you're
gonna be able to split hairs on that but
i do understand what your question is
and and wendy just to add to that point
they pivoted and they did well i thought
i said this earlier you don't know how
long that's going to last
you know the math making business was
insane but as
mass restrictions that that's going to
dip back down and same thing with home
improvement once that
deck is put on or that or that kitchen
is redone it's redone
so they're riding the wave of uh
pivoting and having their best year
ever and it really i know even at the
chamber level we
we didn't do a one-year budget we looked
out two
two and a half years like what came in
here isn't necessary you know the grants
and the funds here isn't necessarily
going to come back again
and things that went virtual are going
to go
that we had to take things virtual the
revenues were down as we get back to in
so looking at that they had a great year
and almost
penalizing that success because that's
what it feels like
um who knows next year
i i think that goes back to the the
revenue versus profits
question and and one thing i can use to
illustrate that
in in our area we have a locally owned
grocery store it was just reported
recently that they had a very very
good year it happens to be a co-op so if
they have
extra funds they can give it back to
their members
however their expenses
have gone up hugely due to
supply chain issues due to
just the cost of goods uh the cost of
transportation
all of those things have increased so
while their revenue may be
up their profits are not and in fact
they've had almost a flat year
so i i think that you know that has to
be
considered as well and and for some of
our other businesses
too construction they had a great year
last year they
you know a lot of people were putting on
those decks and
redoing those kitchens and the cost of
construction materials
i went to buy some pressure treated wood
last
weekend for my garden and almost fell
over
when i was paying over fifteen dollars
for an eight foot board
it's you know the cost of goods has been
just
extraordinary so it it really is
the revenue versus profits issue
mr chairman there follow-up um
yes one follow-up thank you
this revenue versus profit distinction i
think really does need to stay in the
forefront of our mind i'm glad that you
so to to boil this down
every dollar of ppp forgiven which
under the current law becomes a taxed
a taxable dollar is offset by a
qualified
expense and so
effectively there is no tax
on ppp money um
the only question we're really exploring
with sp3
is whether to allow those expenses to
then be taken a second time against
income otherwise earned so if
if you could just agree with me that
it's not the ppp dollars that are
exposed to tax
it's only the extent that there are
profits
beyond the ppv dollars which were offset
by
the things that they paid for so
affecting
so i if i may
i think we've talked about those members
that
but don't know what the future holds so
if you're asking them to pay tax on
dollars
that they did not expect to pay tax on
because
their revenue the ppp dollars are in
their revenue right they're in there
they're in their income stream so
that bumps up their their revenue
and if you're asking them to pay tax on
that that they weren't expecting to pay
and didn't put the dollars aside for
possibly or more importantly
cannot come up with it because they
what the next year holds there are some
businesses that aren't going to recover
until late into 22
some of them into 23 is what they've
told us
so it's the uncertainty i think
that we're that we're talking about here
and
um
oh i agree and the uncertainty and we
can see that with the fact that
uh someone had mentioned it earlier
about uh
you know you're gonna probably have to
pay more
for employees you're gonna have to pay
the lumbers up three times
it it it's um yeah it's the
unpredictability which is
where we were 14 months ago it's
unpredictable
um we're trying our best here but um
question
yeah profits beyond the ppp like i still
feel like
that's theirs instead of it being taxed
on it that's theirs to reinvest either
in keeping their staff
hiring new staff uh anticipating future
expenses that might be increased
i think it's it's got to have a more
long-term vision that
you know it's okay that
okay when do you want to add to that so
i i'm not looking at the future
of what the businesses we're going to
use at it i'm looking at the language
from the ppp loan forgiveness itself
had to be used for certain expenses we
didn't put the money away
it was used for payroll it was used for
rent it was used for keeping us afloat
i can tell you our chamber used it for
the proper reasons and i believe most
businesses did
that money's gone but not only is that
money gone we were making up for the
months and months and months that we had
no income coming in
so i i just think it's a misperception
that there's all this there's been all
this money sitting around i understand
your question
the other thing in talking to um some
accountants was
a lot of the business owners have felt
like this was federal tax money
they already paid taxes and that's where
that money came from
so are we gonna tax it again i'm just
i'm just
i don't know i i'm an attorney by trade
some years ago so that just
that training comes back back to me that
it's already been
taxed income they already paid taxes and
they've got that money back
via the ppp so i it wasn't free money
nobody treated it like free money and if
they did shame on them
but i'm telling you the businesses that
are chamber members and the businesses
that we all helped
that were non-chamber members i can tell
you every person on this call we didn't
care if it was a chamber member or not
we were going to get the best and
fastest information out
because a strong business community
makes a strong economy a strong economy
makes a strong community to live so
that's why we all killed ourselves
trying to help
all the businesses not just our members
so i can tell you very
few didn't the minute we got our check
we were paying ourselves back in other
words because we were had dipped into
our
personal reserves um as business owners
i don't mean the chamber but i'm saying
you know i know businesses that had to
take out a personal line of credit
or take a second mortgage on their house
to keep their businesses afloat
so that when that ppp money arrived so
much later
they were it's like you know they paid
bills and employees out of their own
money
um so i just really can't stress that
that this is not
they don't have a bunch of money lying
around i don't think they're going to
can i add to that just quickly uh mr
chair
yes i wonder if the perspective might be
that this
is an investment that the state can make
in the future of these businesses
rather than trying to collect it from
them um
i because what we're saying is that
because of uncertainty these businesses
don't know what their
future expenses their higher payroll
their higher lumber whatever it is
and i wonder if the the perspective can
shift to an
investment because these businesses are
going to be able to pay bpt
at some point if they stay in business
and they're not going to be able to be
paid bbt ept
if they don't stay in business and i'm
asking you to look at that perspective
okay i would agree with valerie there's
there's so many businesses that are are
just trying to crawl back
out this year and next year is still
looking very uncertain
for them and again costs are rising
exponentially for some of these
businesses
their supply chains have not yet
recovered
i in fact i was talking with a hardware
store yesterday
who said uh their business has been
steady has been good they're one of
those businesses that was
you know in more of the in terms of
retail was in more of the essential
category so they
they are recovering but they cannot get
product
so their business is is not only limited
by the number of people
that they can hire but they cannot
get the product you know their suppliers
are still not back either you can't sell
something
if you can't put it in your store so
really this is about looking towards
the future for these businesses we react
to
the reps certainly i'd like to get to
those two and then i have a final
question
representation i thank you mr chairman
and thank you to the speakers uh you've
made a lot of similar comments
that i've heard from the dover chamber
near the seacoast
i'm glad you highlighted that there are
many reasons for the unemployment
my question is about if the chambers are
thinking about
um the recovery you know as far as
planning for the future
because at least in the seacoast a lot
of the openings are on food service
and it seems to me that the small
percent the currently unemployed people
many of them are not a good match for
food service you know you really have to
have personality
and hustle and stamina in some of those
jobs
and so just isn't a good match and poor
service is not acceptable
to the restaurants it's really not an
option so
you know i just think it's a little more
complicated when you get this close to
the line
of so few unemployed because as you've
said
some people can't work because of child
care some people
can't because um they're still at risk
but i just wondered if within your
chambers
there hasn't been what i want to say
ideas about
kind of doing it the opposite way
looking at the unemployed and seeing
what they could do that you know
relatively quickly you could use them
for
thanks i i'd like to jump on that yes we
have
and and i know that all of my colleagues
and their chambers have as well
um quite a few chambers around the state
have been working diligently doing
various programs for
our businesses including you know
training programs for employees in the
hospitality industry
um working with various partners with
like the
small business development center here
in new hampshire
um you know the center for women
and enterprise and and other regional
development corporations there's quite a
few organizations in the state that are
working together
to try to address workforce issues so
it's something that we are all on top of
um
personally i i think that the 300
stipend that the governor has just
ended or will be ending is a good idea
it does not address all of our issues we
had workforce issues before the pandemic
and the pandemic has made them worse
but you know we're we're almost at the
point where we just really need more
people
we really need more people in this state
to fill the
jobs and that's really becoming our
limiting factor
is the fact that we you know we are an
aging state
our young people have not traditionally
tended to stay in this state and
and it's around a lot of different
issues you know there's so many things
that tie together here the cost of
housing
being one of them child care
and and we're not even we're not even
sure
how many people have dropped out of the
job market for good
you know we're we know that there's 30
000 people on unemployment
that doesn't address how many have just
dropped off
and won't be coming back
um i'd love to chime in a little on that
too because
i was talking with a colleague and um
i think that you know sometimes the
business and economic affairs
talks about the three-legged school with
education
and businesses in the state there's
another three-legged stool that's
out there right now and that's employees
whether it be their age their training
their drive
so you have your employees your
workforce the cost of living
which is you know the houses i had
housing and then the other one was the
wages the benefits and
the life so that's the so it's like
how much your income your expenses and
your talent but that's kind of the new
and again we haven't worked this out but
that's what i was
we have we formed like the commerce
quarter i was talking with a peer in
that that's what the chambers need to
start working at because in the heart of
that
is the business you know the business is
going to get those employees
trained age whatever they're going to
pay those employees but if the cost of
living
whether it be insurance or housing or
whatever that
we're right in the heart of this new
triangle
so i'm on a tangent i think that that's
what we all need to be working on
so if i can if i can just jump in
quickly um i want to be
clear that there are many many jobs that
are open
that are not in the hospitality industry
lonza
is trying to hire like crazy uh zigzal
is trying to hire like crazy
they're just there aren't the bodies and
i think that's
that really is one of the issues um
and i i don't know that house ways and
means has any impact on two things
and i apologize that i that i don't know
this but what we need
is to have these visas for j1s and h2bs
push through so that we can bring in
some of these folks the h2bs
are more the professional folks the j
ones are more the student population
perfect for hospitality um and and i
don't know what what impact house ways
and means can have on that but that's
that's one thing and going back to i
think it was represented
representative spillsberry's question um
i don't know what impact you can have on
vaccinating or getting
messaging out to people about getting
vaccinated there are still too many
people who
say i don't want to be vaccinated i
don't need to be vaccinated the
herd immunity will take care of me yeah
that
that's we're not going to get there
unless we start messaging to people
that they need to get vaccinated and
that's how we get out of this bottom
line is that's how we get out of this
so um that's how we get that's how we
get workers
they get vaccinated um and
and we bring in those who can do the
work that jay wants in the h2b so
if you have any impact whatsoever on
either of those two issues
please help us out i could just make one
quick comment
um i i know not only the question was
about recovery
and not only are uh are getting the
businesses back on their feet
you know and having employees huge and
that's impacting them
but the other thing i would like to
float out there is something i worry
about as a chamber of commerce exact
i worry that as a population are we
going to get back to going out to eat
are we our routines have changed we've
all been hunkered down for months
on end a year and we started ordering
online
we order food online we pick things up
are we ever going to get back to where
we were
and i worry for my businesses that rely
on people to step in the door
um and i just think this compounds the
issue of
taxation on them um if they're worrying
about getting employees but they're also
worried
the future is uncertain are our regulars
and our new customers going to come back
or are they so used to ordering amazon
if you live in my area
i live in amherst but i i commute
through several towns to get to nashua
um i can tell you some of the most
prevalent delivery trucks i see are
amazon
prime and that makes my stomach turn as
a chamber person because that's one more
purchase
that wasn't purchased locally and if we
don't have the local businesses strong
then the communities aren't going to be
strong
and i always tell businesses i always
told my people
you know friends and my own husband um
who ordered pet food online last month
and i was ready to
kick him out now i'm just kidding but um
you know i was like we have a pet store
that's a chamber member up the street
why are you ordering dog food online
because it's easier it comes right to my
house and i worry for our businesses
when your kids were little you went and
asked that business for the scout troop
or the team
could i have a donation that we can
raffle off well those businesses aren't
going to be able to do that if they're
not in business and if we don't support
the businesses in our area
um i feel very strongly about that that
i hope we get back to the typical
patterns
of going to restaurants eating in i know
people are still taking out food and
that aren't sitting down and eating in
restaurants
um i went to one restaurant recently
there used to be like a you know two
hour wait if you didn't have a
reservation or they would never even
take reservations and now the place was
empty on a saturday night so
if you haven't been out in your local
areas to restaurants please take a look
at
how slow business still is okay we have
one more rep to ask you question then i
have a final question
representative early thank you mr chair
i appreciate the uh
acknowledgement i the questions that uh
representative spillsberry
asked were not answered in any way shape
or form
and sorry about the phone it'll stop
the question was
that he asked was since money is coming
in on the ppp
and the ppp uh expenditure for wages
is deductible the
for 80 plus percent of the loan
the net tax liability
is zero so
why do we not
or why do we do sb3 at all if the net
tax liability is going to be zero you've
got
money coming in you've got money written
off as
a legitimate business expense so
if it's zero no tax liability
or very limited tax liability why are we
even discussing
sb3 or alternatively
why aren't we discussing the amendment
that mr
representative spillsberry put forward
to make sure that we don't
allow both writing off the money coming
in
and then writing off
the uh the cost as well
that was not addressed by anyone on the
chamber
they walked around and said we're just
looking for money for the state
there's no money coming into the state
on that
you know in all honesty i am not
familiar enough with
tax code to feel like i could give an
intelligent answer to that
and and i understand the question i i do
understand the question
um is it true that if i bring in a
thousand dollars and i spend a thousand
dollars that
that entire thousand dollars is written
off i don't know enough about taxes to
answer that question so
um i'm sorry i i wish that i could i
agree we we wear many hats as chamber
exacts but being tax experts is not one
of them so i do apologize if we didn't
answer it correctly i think we answered
it as best as we thought the question
was asking
but again i'm not a cpa so i would
yeah i'm texting a cpa right now with
your question
could i just clarify a bit on
on this essentially what the
the uh bill is doing is to provide
a stimulus out of state funds for
something that the feds did
on which is allowing
people to both deduct their expenses and
not have to report the revenue that came
with it
so a lot of other states did that but
they recover it again
from the personal income tax and the
sales tax
which of course we don't so that's why i
think a lot of
of people on the committee are are
ambivalent okay
i i appreciate the clarification
representative almi
um i i s it's a little about taxes
to be able to respond intelligently but
thank you for that clarification
that's a good point tracy do you have
any comments
i i i would have to agree with valerie i
i do that's not where my area of
expertise
lies if i'm understanding this
right i i think what you're saying
is that if sb3 was to be voted in
that the majority of businesses who did
suffer losses
or or had a a level
year with their revenues and expenses
with the ppp
would not be taxed anyways so that
you would only be taxing those that
actually did have a good year
and did do better than they did in 2019
i i think that's what i'm feeling
nope i'm
incorrect then frankly i'm not sure
about that either
okay uh tracy you actually
identified what my question is going to
be
is that in any of your areas
what percentages of your businesses
made enough profit
in tax year that's why
20 to have to
um well i obviously i haven't polled all
of them but if i had to guess
i would say perhaps 30 percent
30 would would be paying no vpt
right that or right
no i'm sorry 30 percent would be paying
bpt
and uh do you have a
i think ours would be closer to 20
because 80
of our chamber members are considered
small businesses
50 and less um of course the sba
definition of a small business
is i think 499 employees or less
and the majority of the economy of the
state of new hampshire is small
businesses
not the big corporations and
donna um i i think
mine's dropped wendy's 20 and um
i'm really i keep seeing the cpa i asked
the question
the little dots are coming and then no
message came through as far as the
previous question
again i'm not a tax expert um but
so anyway and uh valerie
i i also have not polled my members
and i i usually hesitate to respond
unless i've spoken with a number of them
but if we're going to use the the how
many small businesses or what percentage
of our members are small businesses and
we consider that to be 25 people or less
that's 80 of our membership and we have
close to 700 members
so if that's the if that's the formula
that we're using
then i would say that 20 of our
businesses
would be eligible for bpt so
so from what i hear is there's probably
about 20
excuse me
[Music]
so my answer was 20 but but that doesn't
mean
that we know the financial status how
they did this year they're just that's
just the breakdown of
smaller companies versus our larger
companies i mean most chambers are made
up of small businesses not
not the bigger companies we're very
fortunate when we get the
bigger companies because they pay a
little more dues um
but i i think um if i might just say i
think you asked us here today
to give you a boots on the ground report
of how the businesses are doing
and i understand your technical
questions but i think it misses the
bigger picture from where
our standpoint of what our expertise is
the businesses have not fully recovered
anywhere near it they can't find
employees
and i don't know what the future is
going to hold for businesses because
people are so used to
buying online now i'm actually scared to
death for them um and i'm not
exaggerating i'm not
i just i'm just telling you my that's my
professional opinion having been
in this business and on the board i was
a board member before i was um this is
the second chamber i've been the
president of
and i'm telling you that is my
professional opinion
thank you all right any further
comments or questions from the committee
yeah mr chair
uh pat the secretary uh let's not forget
even the businesses that don't make a
profit have to pay the bet and those
employees that were paid by the
pp money so there's still tax obligation
there
so that's something that i just want to
throw out thank you
yes anything else from
anybody if not we certainly appreciate
the four members of the chambers of
commerce being here today because
you've added an awful lot of information
that we didn't have
and we didn't understand and we
appreciate you taking the time
to be here together to share that
information with us
well thank you very much for having us
uh i again i
i think i go you go back to the spirit
in which this money was awarded
was rescue um and
the um if the the
by the federal government even the
federal government said it wasn't
they weren't going to tax it and 40
other states said that
and we don't know what the future holds
so i
i just uh you know our chamber has come
out
very much in support of sb3 and thank
you for your time today
yes thank you very much to the committee
thank you very much for listening to
asking such
uh such great questions thank you thank
you again
thank you for being here thank you yes
thank you for coming
we're very grateful that you're able to
be here thank you
so the next thing we want to do as a
committee
uh let's just take five minutes and then
we'll come back
and listen and we'll have the dra talk
to us
about the timing of the
senate bill three revenue issues
so we'll be back in five minutes which
would be
11 30.
[Music]
so
uh
you
susan there
hi oh thank you for arranging to have
the chambers
here this morning that was very useful
yes i think they provide a very good
perspective
from the area that we don't get a lot of
our taxes from but if they die
i'm afraid that we wouldn't have we'd
have even less
employees at higher levels in the state
yeah i agree i also think they were from
different parts of the state
i thought it was absolutely outstanding
very valuable anecdotes and good
information
i think though that if we really uh
look closely at what they said they've
identified a lot of useful things that
potential would help but aren't within
the end but if the ways and means
like increasing the vaccination
vaccination rate and
getting kids back to school and child
care vouchers and j-1 and h-2b
visas and you know there's all kinds of
things that
are we back in order now or not uh
because
uh discussion of stuff you know 91a and
all that
happy horse we seem to be recording
we're still recording i would like to
point out
what's going to happen all summer uh
janine and jen the dra
have you let them through yes they're
here
okay sentence
we're back in action and the dra is here
and they
have provided us to email
the senate bill 3 fiscal impact
timing and if they
would explain this we would certainly
appreciate it
so caroline are you the one that take
the lead on this
yes mr chair thank you for having us
carolyn lear assistant commissioner
with the new hampshire department of
revenue um it sounds like you all have
the document that we forwarded to you
last night would it also be helpful if i
[Music]
that's it and much bigger print very
nice
i anticipated that you'd want to see the
i had my magnifying glass at my desk
so i'm suggesting we're old
there's nothing to do with age i'm
suggesting the numbers are the most
important part of
so i'll just go over briefly the
methodology
that we um we undertook
to try to parse out the fiscal
impact of senate bill 3 by
state fiscal year so as you previously
heard
we have estimated the all-in potential
fiscal impact of senate bill 3
to be just under 100 million dollars
we'd previously not attempted to
allocate this fiscal
impact to a particular fiscal year
because
really the fiscal impact is very
sensitive
to when and if senate bill 3 becomes
law for example if
senate bill 3 had become law prior to
april 15th you would have seen a far
larger fiscal impact
in fiscal 21 but it did not um
for purposes of estimating the timing of
senate bill 3
we've assumed that all taxpayers are
calendar year filers
that aligns with our data which is that
approximately 90 percent of our filers
are calendar year filers but also of
note
is that our fiscal filers skew towards
the largest multinational companies
um which we don't think is necessarily
the demographic of business most
impacted
by senate bill 3. um we've assumed that
taxpayers would report um
ppp loan forgiveness in the year
the loan is actually forgiven
um and we have done our best
to sort of predict um
when these loans will be forgiven by the
sba
certainly for round one of the uh
paycheck protection loan program we have
some
actual forgiveness data i think at the
end of
april about 50 of the total loan
issuance
had been forgiven at that time with the
second round
it was entirely speculation because
those
loans um aren't really being forgiven at
any meaningful level
yet
after trying to place the
the loan in the correct um calendar year
for the taxpayer then we then
undertook an analysis of when
that loan forgiveness would be predicted
to impact the amount of taxes that they
pay to the department
to come up with a fiscal year impact and
lastly and
most i think most importantly based on
some of the discussions that we've had
with you
over the course of the last several
weeks our analysis acknowledges
that for many taxpayers the overall
impact of senate bill 3 will result
in either the creation of a credit
carryover
or a net operating loss which is why you
see the fiscal impact
here spread into later
fiscal years so in fiscal year 25
through 28
the reason why you see fiscal impacts in
those years is because that we have
presumed that some proportion
of ppp loans reported in a tax year
will generate either an nol or a credit
carryover
and therefore the fiscal impact won't be
felt by the state
until that cco or nol is utilized by the
taxpayer to actually offset
with that i am happy to answer any
questions
well thank you carolyn uh representative
elena
thank you mr chairman i actually have
two areas after what we've just listened
to
but on the most important one i think
for this is that there are
on a lot of water's edge companies
whose filings include their subsidiaries
and their subsidiaries would have
so at least some of them been eligible
for the ppp loans
on and it sounds to me like you're
disregarding those at this point do you
have any way
of knowing
how many subsidiaries below a certain
size would be in those companies
i actually looked into this question
representative because i heard you bring
it up yesterday
our returns the new hampshire business
water's edge business tax return does
not have a place
for a taxpayer to list their
subsidiaries
um a waters edge return does require
a large stack of attachments
and within those attachments
a water's edge company would be expected
to inventory their subsidiaries all this
with
all of the subsidiaries that are flowing
up for that return
but that would be a very manual process
of going through those pages
it's not scanned um and
put into our system um it's primarily
used in an
audit so an auditor would be picking up
those pages and looking at them
to see the subsidiaries included on that
return
well yes so for the water's edge
companies we're really back where we
were
15 years ago when all the forms were in
the basement
and somebody had to go look through them
to answer a question that's that's
really interesting thank you
on the the other one is related to
the um the chambers of commerce people
we've
been listening to and i don't know if
you heard any of that
but they are
really worried they they represent
mostly small
and small businesses
in the new hampshire side
size businesses and medium businesses in
that
and they figured when
the chair asked them that only about 20
to 30 percent
of their businesses were were actually
likely at any time to be paying vpt
um but they are terrified of
that those businesses are are still
struggling
to stay alive and that
not passing sp3 would just
would destroy those businesses do you
i'm not sure uh well if you uh
if they're right about those
businesses there would probably be more
showing up
in 22 because they would be using they
wouldn't be doing credit carry forward
they'd be pulling credit carry forward
so i'm going to review your question to
make sure i understand it first before i
answer something you didn't ask um so is
your question
how would the fiscal impact present
itself
for a business that did pay on
ppp in their 2020
taxes
representative you're muted i thought
i'd
unmute it sorry the small businesses
on that are medium enough
that they have been paying bpt
on they think are in a position
where they're still struggling to stay
alive
or they managed to stay alive this last
year
but next year they will no longer be
building a lot of patios or
or on
selling selling a product like
hand sanitizer and we'll have to go back
to something else that maybe isn't as
profitable
anymore and therefore
are still in the struggling category as
to whether they're going to survive
and if they get if they don't
if they have to pay
pay on some of their profits during
during last year on
they they would want
that money back right away or
um if they have credit carry forward
from the previous year
right so our analysis assumes a
historical
rate of cco um
utilization and um reporting
so i guess to your point if they're
going to be
extra motivated to receive a refund
instead of a cco
for example um then i think you're
correct
that in the fiscal 22 and fiscal 23
years you could see a greater fiscal
impact
um but alternatively
i think if you
assume that a greater proportion than
normal
of taxpayers are going to generate ccos
because or generate nols because of just
the overall economic
conditions then you could see an even
more delayed
fiscal impact i think there are a lot of
unique factors to
these coveted pandemic tax years
that could um
both increase and decrease the fiscal
impact in any
also if they do have ccos they're going
to be
immediately reducing their estimates if
they're
they're cash poor and a fair number of
these businesses
on got personal loans or
remortgage their houses in order to keep
going and
and i definitely understand that logic
and instinctively
it seems correct that taxpayers would
reduce their estimate payments
what's interesting is that during the
course of the pandemic we actually went
back and looked what happened during the
prior recession
to see if taxpayers did modify their
estimate payments
to reflect the prevailing economic
conditions under the belief that you
know if you really needed that money you
were going to be
motivated to reduce your estimate
payments as low as you could justify
and we didn't see that happening during
the prior recession
um that doesn't mean that it won't
happen during this recession
they're they're completely different for
sure um
but i don't know that it's a certainty
that's really interesting i'd just like
to point out that the last recession
lasted about four years here
in those terms but it was in our
revenues more i think than it was
in the businesses they recovered before
we did
so they were paying less
okay reps on early
thank you mr chair um going back to the
cco and nols
it appears as though we may be headed
into a period of inflation
and your timing uh shows
a rather high loss period if i'm reading
that right am i
am i reading that correct 23 is going to
be the hit year
yes you're correct so if we have
inflation
is the hit going to be either as bad or
is it going to be worse
for the overall revenues coming into the
state
if inflation does in fact take place
because of all the money that's being
well it's not being created it's not
coming from anything real it's just
being printed
so am i
looking at that the right way i i'm a
little confused on that one
i don't know if uh melissa rollins has
any thoughts on that
i'm a lawyer by trade so the economics
of it
are not my strong suit
uh thank you representative lori for
your question um
it's a good question we haven't analyzed
that
um i think you're right if it does
inflation um we have been keeping an eye
on it
it's a little controversial right now if
you've read any of the articles whether
it's going to continue or whether this
is just sort of a true up
from where the pandemic was um
i've read articles both on from
economists saying it could go
um either way so
i think if it does continue
right if inflation does hit and this
isn't just a pandemic situation
then it could be
more a bigger hit however the inflation
will hit
everything across the board so it could
even it out
um however based on like i said what
we've been reading
we're definitely keeping an eye on it
but um it seems like most economists
think that the inflation
is peaking because of how low it was a
year ago
um with the pandemic and that this
should just be
a blip and then it will normalize in the
next couple of months
uh let's hope so thank you okay
before we go to representative brownie
the cco that you use in this analysis is
that
the way we're doing things now without
the change in the law as suggested in
house bill too
that's correct the it's based on current
law
meaning that there's no cap in the
amount of cco that a taxpayer can carry
forward
okay and if if we did
if hb2 did pass
the raid as opposed
uh how much would this change
the figures in this table
so i think what you would see primarily
is
you see a 19.2 million total impact
in fiscal year 2024. i think a good
proportion of that would actually hit in
because you would see more refunds and
fewer credit carryovers as well as
perhaps a larger
impact in 2022 okay
when we're talking about ccos and
they're talking about
the corporate tax rate and suggested
going from 21
to 28 knowing that the cco
last year has gotten up to about 275
million dollars
i don't know what the cco looks like
this year
but assume it's not dropping
uh then that that could
affect our cash flow
coming up in this future years
um did you have any data any updated
data on where we are with
ccos this year i don't i don't um
we normally don't rerun the numbers
until july
yeah so i think to your question
representative um
to the extent that taxpayers change
their behavior
and instead of claiming cco's
claim refunds that could certainly
impact
um cash flow in this state
um what we don't know is whether that's
likely to happen or not
okay representative thank you mr chair
i got a couple of cookies uh first
before i go to the chart
i just want to make sure i have the
numbers right how many
do we know how many companies received
ppp loans
how many companies what how many
companies in new hampshire receive the
ppp
loan round one and round two okay
i'm trying to see quickly if we have it
in our fiscal note
and while you're looking how many
dollars total
so the total dollars are 814 billion
no that's for the whole not for are you
for now were you asking for just new
hampshire yes new hampshire
i can get you we can get you the uh
total numbers
for um numbers and dollars for new
hampshire i don't have them handy
but you know where to get it though
right
okay well fine if we can get that that
would be great so
when i'm when i'm looking at the chart
so if you had to give a plus or minus
of impact financially
uh would you what kind of a plus or
minus would you put around it
five percent ten percent
it's going to fall within a range like
for 22 you have 25.4 million
is that is that give or take five
percent either way
or ten percent either way uh you know
what i mean
i mean so i so i think what i would say
i don't
quickly have a percentage but i would
say
sort of the worst case scenario i would
see
is that the fiscal impact in 25
26 27 and 28
actually occurs in 22 23 24
along with what is already reported
there so that roughly
10 million that you have spread across
25 through 28
if that gets actually claimed in
22 23 and 24 that would be sort of
the maximum fiscal impact right so
that's
that's the way to view this is that the
tough year is going to be 23
it starts in 22 19 and 24
then after that it's really uh
manageable
very manageable at the you know 1.7
million to 4.4 million
uh range so that's his trailer issue
that we have to deal with down the road
so okay so i have one more mr chair
yesterday when we were discussing the
actual bill
i i made this i made the comment that
that no matter what the ppp
loan expenses that are used
would be deductible as a business
expense
whether sp3 passed or not i just wanted
to get from the dra
correct right that's that's what i
thought uh
representatives mr pillsbury uh uh
pointed to
roman two in the bill and my
my interpretation of roman two in the
bill no deduction shall be denied
no tax attribute shall be reduced
no basic uh basis increase shall be
denied
by a reason of exclusion from gross
business income provided
by paragraph one and i said that that
was just covering it i mean
uh that that it still would be
whether we passed this bill or not the
the
uh the deduction of this
expense
[Music]
that uh were that were gained from the
the loan or the forgiven loan
uh is is there uh so
okay you're verifying that correct
correct i i'm fighting my best urges a
bit to get into the weeds with you on it
but i think really paragraph two is
necessary because under normal
tax law if an item of
income is excluded then under
standard tax law the expense would be
disallowed
so roman 2 and the bill is really felt
in suspenders to make
clear that despite the fact that we're
excluding the income
we're still going to allow the expenses
because otherwise that wouldn't be the
standard tax
treatment but you are correct that under
current law as well as under sb3
in both of those scenarios the expenses
will be allowed okay thank you
just wanted to make sure that i put a
little doubt in my mind that
that because that's been my view the
whole time thank you
uh mr chairman yes represent
that data about the reduction
non-reduction in estimated payments
it doesn't during the great recession it
doesn't quite
jibe with the fact that in fact we lost
fair amount of revenue in the business
taxes during those four years
yeah and we looked at we what we looked
at representative was
a single year when we where we felt
that the the taxpayers should have
felt the re recession and therefore
should have um should have adjusted
their estimates and they did not
but then in later years of course they
year
just for future information
i've asked the dra to put together a
table similar to this which
goes out beyond the next biennium of 22
and 23
that would show the effect
of the tax reductions that we put into
meals and rooms rate going to eight and
a half percent
the bet threshold to 250 thousand
dollars the bet rate to 0.55
and the change in the bpt
credits due to
uh also business tax credit carry
forward
single sales factor and the bpt rate
going to 7.6
they will carry forward that through
those years
how this meshes with
senate bill 3 so that once we
get out of the next biennium where do we
stand
relative wise in revenue when we take
all these things
other changes and revenues into
consideration
and hopefully we'll have that from the
dnr
soon how is that coming
[Music]
melissa
we are just about finished editing it
and it should be over to you
i would think carolyn within the day
okay so that i would think so
fine we're not scheduled for another
meeting until next
tuesday but if you get it back
and get it to me as soon as you can i
can discuss it and then
send it to the full committee so they
can go over it
prior to our next meeting
any further questions of the dra uh
representative tucker
well i just wanted to say i'm delighted
you asked for that
i i think there are a lot of different
places that
adjustments could be made and it's
important to have that
the answers to your question thank you
very much for
asking the dra to do that we need to
understand the
relationship between all these different
bills
and their facets and changes in rates
right we always seem to when we make a
reduction in taxes we seem to
on the front part of it not have
affect much but it goes into the outer
ears and we need to understand that
yeah thank you very much any further
questions
if not we're right on time
um hopefully uh
emily block brockton
is available jen
have you heard from her it doesn't look
like she's signed on
quite yet um
i know her eleven o'clock was going to
run up
real close to noon but i have not heard
anything
from her yet okay if the committee
doesn't mind uh
why don't we take a 10 minute break
and come back at 12 10. and hopefully by
that time
emily's here that's what emily
will do she'll have the latest on the
rules
in order to be able to utilize the
american recovery funds that
are going to be distributed to all the
states of 1.9 trillion dollars
which we need to understand so i have to
leave the meeting for a little bit
and i'll try to get back okay
or 12 make it 12
15 and take grab a quick sandwich
okay
hi mr chairman thank you for having me
again oh we're excited to have you
[Laughter]
so you've had a pretty busy morning
you know we we did talk with treasury we
also did a webinar for our members had 3
that's questions five questions per
person
fifteen hundred questions i mean one a
second is quite a bit
[Music]
[Laughter]
well we it is 12
16 um looks like
most everybody's getting back here
we'll wait another couple of minutes how
much time do you have
so i do have a hard stop at the top of
the next hour at one
um but i think i can run through this in
about 30 minutes
good
but we're likely to have more than that
janine or john
yep we're going to be recording this so
that we'll be able to
revisit it yes that's correct everything
oh wait one more minute and then we'll
normal i think most of us are back 17
are back
we know jen wasn't going to be back i'm
thanks all right then we can get started
we were fortunate to have emily
swanson brought back and
she was scheduled for 11 but then she
got pulled away to
but she was able to join us shortly
after noon time
and hopefully she'll have some good
information
on what the rules are and how we can use
the american recovery funds
that we'll be getting so emily it's
all yours thank you so much mr chairman
as i i said before
i it's a real pleasure to come meet with
you guys again and
while i hope to have um answers to many
of the questions that we discussed
in the last time that we meet that we
met
um there are still several unanswered
questions but i'll be
very clear about what those are that we
keep encouraging treasury to provide
us because you know there are some
significant voids
um and information but there is a lot of
really good stuff that they gave us so
we're pretty excited
um there's a lot of information to
process and there's a lot of um
source material that they've provided so
let me let me
dive right in you will you'll be able to
email me copy this so we can get a
distributor there
yes yes and throughout the document i
would say too
before we get started i reference
specific page numbers of where i
found that information in the source
document so if you do
revisit um a specific clause that i
discussed i i
put you directly to where i found that
information or my team found that
information so
so the law was enacted on march
10th i spoke with you in the april time
frame
and then here we are in may we were kind
of guessing that probably treasury would
um take a lot of time to really think
and put out careful
um guidance and they did so on
may 10th exactly 60 days
after enacting the law and according to
the law that's when they had to do it by
they released what's called an interim
final rule
and gfoa members uh have said to me a
couple times well that's an oxymoron how
can it be interim
and final at the same time well indeed
it is not final final
um this is expedited rulemaking from the
united states treasury and that's why
they call it an interim final
rule but within the uh within the rule
itself
there's a lot of questions sprinkled
throughout it's like what should
it does this work for your entity what
should we include how
how could this be a better final rule
with your input so
feedback is solicited for this interim
final rule
and comments are due by july 17th so 60
days from
may 17th would be july 17th um the
united states treasury also put out an
faq sheet which is um
a good digestible way of understanding
the interim final rule they've asked
sort of plain english questions and
they've tried to answer each question
with links so that's
that's a really nice document and then
they also have a fact sheet that they've
put out
um one thing that's missing from this
guidance and this is the
one thing that we truly are very
frustrated about is the fact that we
do not have any more guidance than we
did on non-entitlement units
we know that states have been assigned a
specific allocation
of what that any in the eu's or the
aggregate of the non-entitlement units
is coming their way but the frustrating
part is right now we
don't know who's calculating the 75
threshold who it who is um
a sub-recipient of whom um if there is
any interrelated uh
concepts that we need to make sure that
we let any use aware
of um so so for example let me be a
little bit more clear
um you know if there is a
non-entitlement unit
and they are eligible they obviously are
eligible to receive money from the
american rescue plan
we need to know who does that 75 percent
of their most recent budget calculation
is it the state or is it the treasury
then we need to know
how do those smaller entities certify
that money
did they talk to the state or do they
talk to the treasury
and then the third thing is we need to
know if those small
local governments are sub-recipients of
the state which means then
they would be held to the same rules of
the state
so those reporting relationships are
also important so
we're continuing to sort of urge
treasury that was point of the call is
to
just now is to urge them to bring forth
more information as much information as
we could possibly
help them to distribute on this
non-entitlement unit
because as you know states have
an extension of 30 days past
may 10th to distribute the funds to the
non-entitlement units
then states can appeal one more time
for an additional 30 days to the
treasury to distribute those funds
at the end of the day the legislation
says states have to get this money to
the non-entitlement units
by july 10th states can't do that
until we have more information from
treasury
that there's a lot of critical
information that we're missing here so
we're pressing the treasury trying to
get them to give us
um specifically who's responsible for
what
okay so now we'll jump into for
the guidance in particular i'm going to
talk about three big pillars number one
process and certification number two
eligible use of proceeds and number
three
reporting requirements so those are the
three big pillars that the guidance has
provided us
in this in this um in this guidance that
they put out
number one certification
for jurisdictions that are eligible to
receive money directly from the treasury
that means
counties and cities above 50 000 in
population
they have to go to the united states
treasury website to certify
the proceed and they have to have two
separate people to do that
number one they have to have an
administrator of the account
and number two they have to have an
executive of the account so
the administrator of the count is the
person who receives information from the
treasury and maybe dispatches it out
into her organization but the what's
really caught the ire of a lot of people
who are certifying right now
is that the treasury is being
exceptionally
um careful about who
can who can be the administrator of the
account so they've gone through
an identification process a rigorous
identification process for people who
certify gfoa members have said
they have to present their social
security number
their driver's licenses their facial
scan and in the event that
a couple of gfoa members told me that
their facial scan failed i guess because
of covet or something i don't know
um and then they had to surrender
medical records so
a tremendous amount of private finance
private information for the
administrator of the account and when we
do talk with treasury and
we say there are local policies that
prohibit you know providing this type of
information
the treasury is just kind of like i'm
sorry but we need to make sure that
person is who they say that they are
so id dot me is the only choice and
there's a lot of information that they
um that they then um have to provide
now in terms of the process
you know the id me process is is is
is what it is um but in terms of the
timing a lot of gfoa members have said
is there a timeline do i have to do this
by a certain date
and in the guidance it does not set a
timeline so there's no
ultimate timeline um but
what we do advise gfy members of course
is that
you know your first tranche starts the
clock ticking on your second tranche so
to the extent that you can certify
sooner
then that means when your second tranche
comes out one year after you receive
your first
then it the sooner the better for your
budgeting purposes
um so those are things that we've kind
of pulled out of the guidance in terms
of process
okay now we'll talk into eligible use of
proceeds and i wanted to
make sure first to talk about what the
guidance says in very
broad terms so what
what qualifications matter as you
approach these proceeds
in in a lump sum as you're looking at
the money
you see it in your account what are the
broad statements what are the things i
can do with it and what are the things i
can't do with it
so one of the things that we discussed
the last time we talked is that that
covered period question can i use these
funds
retroactively or do i only can i only
use these funds
prospectively and what the united states
treasury said in the guidance
on page 88 is that um
the covered period unless otherwise
noted is march 3rd 2021
of this year through december 31st 2024
so a bracket of march 3rd to december
31st 24 is that period of time
that governments can obligate the funds
and that's an important distinction
actually actually a
a very um sort of liberal interpretation
i think of the law
because then what they say is you can
obligate those funds by 2024 but you
don't have to spend them
until 2026.
so it's an accounting term basically
says
you tie up the funds and promises before
2024 but you have until 2026 to
expend them this uh this this special
notification
is important for those who are using the
proceeds for infrastructure
so you've contracted with the company to
provide a parking lot for example
that parking lot won't be completed
through various contracting services
through 2026
and that's um that that's that's
specifically what that's getting to
there
the law says you cannot spend the funds
on pension deposits
so basically what that means is pension
deposits are a
lump sum added into the asset structure
of your pension fund
that's an important distinction that
they make because they also say
if you are paying pensions as a benefit
that is a part of payroll those are
excluded
from that prohibition so you can't take
the funds as a lump sum and put it into
your pension fund
states cannot spend the funds to reduce
taxes or to delay a tax increase
guidance went actually a little bit
further into
that question that we had about whether
this applies to states and locals
or just states because as we read the
legislative text
we only saw it in section 602 so we said
this must only be
a state prohibition and the guidance
verifies that they say
when we're talking about the uh this
prohibition that
you cannot spend the funds to reduce
taxes or delay a tax increase we're
talking about
only states we are not talking about
local governments so
a lot of gfoa members are local
governments and their consideration
here of course is that well it doesn't
apply to me so if i'm talking about
property taxes or local collections
um then then that prohibition doesn't
apply
and last but not least in this this we
we could use a little bit more clarity
from the treasury but they say
you can't use these funds as a
non-federal match
or other federal programs like for
example if you have
medicaid payments that's what um that's
the non-federal match that they had
referred to
but there are other scenarios so and
they also talk about
um just sort of the relationship
sometimes for local governments is if
the federal government funds flow
through the state
be sure not to classify them as state
proceeds because they are indeed coming
from the federal government so
big overarching no-no's and and
and captures of time for that covered
period is something that we kind of pull
down now as you can see from the page
numbers the frustrating part
is that this was like in the middle of
the text it wasn't like at the beginning
and it wasn't at the end so you have to
search for these
um and so just providing those as as
as we come across them and trying to
reconcile them okay so now let's go into
specific eligible expenditures that's
covered in the guidance
and let's go back to the legislative
text remember all that
legalese that we were kind of battling
with we were trying to figure out what
is eligible what is ineligible eligible
category use a
is that you can use the proceeds on
coven 19 or a negative economic impact
of it
lgbt premium pay for eligible workers
eligible you see for government services
to the extent of the loss of revenue
and eligible uc was the easy one with
the fewest words
investment in water sewer and broadband
infrastructure
the key point about these four eligible
uses is number one it's the same it's
the exact same words
between section 602 and 603 and what
that means is
these are exactly the same for states as
they
are local governments so the law is
equal
in the way that um the eligible use
categories applies
to the states as it does to the locals
and the second thing that's most
important about this is that
every item is mutually
exclusive and what that means is you
don't have to satisfy the conditions
of eligible you see in order to use the
proceeds to pay for
an eligible use a category
and i think a lot of gfoa members have
gotten hung up on that they're trying to
combine the categories they're trying to
look at things and say
well emily i've recouped this revenue so
can i use it on buying
um uh ambulatory services or
ambulances well you know the answer is
you don't have to recoup revenue to
spend money on
eligible use category a you can just
spend it
and that i think is a key element for uh
smaller jurisdictions in particular to
understand
you can do just a and you can do just c
and just b and just d
you don't have to satisfy the conditions
of any of the other eligibilities
categories
so let's talk about them in individual
segments let's jump into the
very first eligible use a category
carbon 19 or
negative economic impacts of it now this
is by far
the most generous of
all of the of all of the categories
there's a significant amount should i
stop i'm happy to take um
your questions as i go along
um one of the things
is you mentioned
the state and can reduce
tax i mean locals could reduce taxes
but the state could how about the county
yes the county can so so the uh
cities counties and towns um
can use the funds to reduce or delay or
offset a tax increase
thank you yep representative romney has
a question
yeah i want to ask this question now
because we may run out of time because
this is a real specific question
that we need answered we're not a
conforming state
so that we have to take legislative
action to if
the uh forgive the uh
forgiven loans not being treated as
revenue
for taxable reasons so
we're struggling with that right now and
if we pass a bill that we have it's
going to cost the state 99.4 million as
they have to call it 100 million
the question is can some of this money
from this program
be used to offset that 100 million
if we're not because we're not a
conforming state and i guess the bigger
question is conforming states
uh do they get a buy on that because
they were already conforming and by our
legislation we're going to conform after
the fact
they had already conformed right uh
right um i remember right the
conformance
understood the question is can we use
the money out
of the arpa funds that we received to to
reimburse that um 99 million dollars
my knee jerk reaction here and i think
that we probably need to verify this
with the state but my knee-jerk reaction
is that the um the reimbursement
for non-conformance in that period of
time is backward-looking and not
forward-looking
and so the treasury may have
i know this might not be the answer that
you want to hear but because the covered
period starts march 3rd 2021
and um that activity happened prior to
march 3rd
2021 then they probably will not
be very likely to cover that
so if we had our bill passed before
march march 3rd
we would have been okay and signed by
the governor
we had on
something from the treasury saying that
the ppp loans
can you check on that
emily i'm happy to yes i'm absolutely
happy to make that question
and and you know what actually i
probably will engage
the national council of state
legislatures and nga along with us
so that we can all ask that question
together um
certainly happy to engage treasury on
that okay
why don't we take another question from
i guess there it is i found it
uh the question is if there's a
difference between conforming in
non-conforming states
and a benefit is given to the conforming
states
to the detriment of the non-conforming
states with the non-conforming states
that have legal action against the
i think that's an absolutely fair point
but i guess
i guess maybe i'm going back to the key
part of the guidance that says
you know if you were conforming prior to
the covered period here
then that is a that's a whole other
that's a whole other
situation than now
which is that you are in the process of
conforming
and therefore have occurred these
expenses or accrue these taxes on the
ppp forgivables
and so i think it's timing that is the
major
question here and i would urge obviously
urge the treasury to cover it but
i'm not sure if they've addressed it yet
well
representative then uh why don't you
continue to ask
representative yeah uh just very quickly
on page 86 in the middle
on there it of the guidance
there is a statement that on
the treasury has determined and
previously announced that income tax
changes even those made during the
covered period
that simply conform with recent changes
in federal law
for taxation of loan forgiveness under
the paycheck protection program are
permissible
under the offset provision and i figured
that that
covered it permissible under the offset
provision
of the coverage change
i left out on the
federal taxation of unemployment
insurance
i know those hands up but i'd like to
make sure
emily finishes her presentation and
whatever time is left because she
he has a drop that time of one o'clock
whatever time is left we'll
deal with the questions go ahead and
annoy
thank you and you know to be honest i'm
i'm looking at that
section right now with fresh eyes um
certainly from your perspective
and i do need to do a little bit of
research to be firm
in in this but we'll absolutely reach
out to the treasury if they determine
this is
impermissible but looking at
the cover change i'm trying to figure
out
where it is whether or not it is a
revenue recoupment
category or a covid 19 expenditure
that i think is an important distinction
but i will go back to that for sure
thank you
um okay so in the taxation yes
so in in terms of elsewhere's category a
um
remember this is a very generous portion
of
what cities counties and states can do
with this money
moving 19 and negative economic impacts
includes public health emergency
it includes public health and safety
payroll it includes
capital investments in public facilities
so they go into it
in fact the real estate of the guidance
27 pages is dedicated to just this
category so a significant fortune
of the guidance is dedicated to what you
can do
as responding to coven 19. now what
we're telling gfoa members is
if you find something that falls within
these categories
that you're asking if it's an eligible
use and you can tie it back to covet 19
mitigating covered 19. it's very often
the answer is yes especially if you're
talking about capital investments if
health care and any kind of health care
expenditures
but i think more importantly what a lot
of folks are kind of zoning in on again
is that question about is public health
and safety payroll covered
and indeed we found that on page 21 that
public health and safety payroll is
covered including
the benefits that are including the
benefits that are associated with that
payroll so
a significant chunk of money operating
money
for local governments is included in
this
category in particular but remember you
can only
cover the public health and safety
payroll from march 3rd
to december 31st 2021. so that's
included
then they go into the negative economic
impacts
that is even much broader and i know
last time we talked
um uh i i believe we talked about the
fact that um hospitality taxes flow
through the state and then are
redistributed i think that's what
maybe we we have talked about in new
hampshire and
um indeed uh what it says for an
eligible use of proceeds is that
um it is of course tax revenue is
considered here but also
direct direct grants and direct help to
industries that were impacted by
covid19 is covered so if there's
any kind of capital improvements that
your businesses need to do
then you can go ahead and use these
funds to help um
both businesses and tourism industry you
know in your state
so i think that that's an important
luxury that you're kind of opening up
pandora's box and they're saying you can
do all of these things
um local governments are probably going
to start asking well can i give
benefits directly to citizens so to the
extent that there's food insecurity or
there's
um um or there is
um uh utilities in arrearages
um can i help those citizens with that
situation and what the guidance says is
that
you can use the money to provide those
social services
in your community but then they're also
very clear about the fact that if the
covered period begins on march 3rd 2021
if there were a rearranges in utility
bills that occurred prior to that
we're pressing the treasury again to say
can we cover a rear edges to make sure
those people can get to today
can get to right now so those are all it
really is a very
large category that then would allow for
people to use these proceeds in a
variety of different ways
and and and to be to be honest many of
them are operating expenditures
so your local governments your state
government could use this on
operating funds you can you can
you can figure out how to use these
money on operating expenditures so that
then
you might be able to deposit proceeds
into your
um into your rainy day or your reserve
funds um as a as an alternative with
those otherwise
um operating operating funds
okay so putting that shelf back again
remember everything
in that category has to be qualified
back to mitigating covet 19
then you kind of pull out the next book
which is the premium pay for eligible
workers
and this one as opposed to 28 pages this
one was
about five pages so much smaller what it
says
is you can pay a workers 13
per hour up to a total maximum of 25 000
and the executive has to make a
determination of who's eligible
in the jurisdiction lots of
jurisdictions have called us back and
said
hey i want to provide premium pay to
all of my employees lots of counties
have actually talked about that
if i want to pay for all of my employees
are there any conditions that i need to
be aware of
and yes indeed in the guidance there is
one condition
you cannot pay over a hundred fifty
percent
of the average wage of the state or the
county that the worker resides in
whichever is greater and if you do pay
over 150 through this premium pay
bonus then you have to justify it
so a lot of counties are calling and
saying who's justifying and what kind of
words are they using how are they
justifying it so
there there's we're currently in
development kind of thinking about how
they might be able to apply premium pay
and also conditionally premium pay
can be paid retroactively throughout the
guidance it says
you can use this money to pay for 2020.
and so gfoy members are calling and
saying do i just pay him a check
now like based on the last 18 months or
how do i do this and the guidance
doesn't go into process of how to make
those premium payments
but it does say they're sort of kind of
opening it up broader
and the last thing i'd say about premium
pay is that
it's not just limited to the employees
of the government
the guidance made it much larger the
guidance they said
you can pay other workers in your
community through
grants whether they are food production
facilities grocery stores
restaurants janitors truck drivers they
kind of
really open that up quite a bit actually
probably more than i would argue the
legislative intent was
but they said you can use this for
providing grant revenue in order to pay
that premium pay to those folks in your
economy
okay putting that book back on the shelf
and i'm pulling out
probably the most vexing part of the
legislation
and that is you can use it for
government services to the extent
that your government lost revenue and
treasury has tackled this issue in a
very
important way they've said okay
we know that everybody has lost some
revenue at a certain point in time
and we also know that jurisdictions have
levied
or have increased millage for um
in order to accommodate for that dip in
revenues and all of this all of these
different sorts
of of changes that are happening between
and among all the local governments and
the state governments because remember
this law this this written rule is the
same for states and local governments
and so what the treasury has said is
that we need a little bit of data we
need to control
the environment here we need to control
the inputs
and we need to control the outputs
because this definition is so broad
so here's how they try to control it
they try to control it by asking
everyone to identify what their base
year is the base year is the
most recent closed uh year
financial year fiscal year that you have
in your organization so if it's
um if it's july to june
uh 2019 then that's your most
recent full fiscal year and that's what
they call
your base year revenue that base your
revenue is representative
of a normal year for you and they say
actually look back three years because
if you look
and you look back three years and you
see that there's a growth rate that
happened between 2016 and 2019
and it is greater than 4.1 percent use
that as a growth rate
otherwise we're going to assume
everybody can grow
at 4.1 which is actually a pretty
generous
growth rate and then they say okay
for every december 31st over the covered
period we need you to check
your actual revenue collected
and if your actual revenue collected on
december 31st of every year
is less than that projected revenue
based on that 4.1
growth or greater then you get to
collect that gray part
that gray part that's underneath that's
above the black part and
underneath that diamond you get to
collect that gray part now
lots of dfy members have said well what
if the black part what if the actual
revenues collected was above
that projection well then you can
collect zero
is the answer to that so these are the
data that you need to come to the table
with but they've complicated it a little
bit as only treasury can
and they said okay we have to qualify
what kind of revenues can be captured
in this in this revenue calculation
and because they can rely on sort of
census of government's data
they've said that there's certain
information that's outside of the
revenue calculation
federal transfers are out you can't
include those in your revenues
you can't include you can't double count
your inter-governmental transfers they
say
no they also say you can't include
revenues from utilities
and the reason for that is because they
say well you know
utilities generally um
receive assistance from the governments
that they're in
it's very rare that utilities provide
assistance to
the governments and so they say exclude
utilities and they define utilities as
water supply
they do not refer to sewerage which is a
very interesting thing so it's just
clean safe drinking water electric gas
and public mass transit system so you
have to exclude those from the revenue
calculation
exclude right refunds and other
correcting transactions and exclude
anything you receive from the issuance
of debt and for states it says
you have to exclude your liquor store
revenues in that calculation
then they say okay well then if it feels
like they've excluded a lot
but then what is in and essentially what
they say is everything else
taxes fees other revenues to support
public services including component
units and enterprise funds
which as you can imagine there's myriad
different things
that counties and cities can have that
create fees like zoos or
parking or civic centers or things like
that can all fall under
revenue categories that can be captured
what can you
do with the revenue so a second sorry
next what you do is you say how okay
i've determined my revenue now what do i
do with it so you look at your night
2019 base year revenue
and you project the revenue at 4.1
percent or greater
and then that multiplier you have to
figure out at every december 31st of
every year
how much you've collected in actual
revenues this is
tough for a lot of local governments
again because our
fiscal year wraps around that december
31st figure
and there's a lot of accruals that
probably haven't happened or closed
by december 31st so that's that is a
that is an awkward period of time and we
will be commenting the treasury on that
because it just simply is very hard for
a lot of people to show actuals on
december 31st but that nevertheless
that's what they say in the guidance and
then of course
if you're if your projected growth
exceeds
i'm sorry if your actuals exceeds your
projected growth then
obviously your collection is zero for
that year now
there is a condition too so once you've
decided how much you're going to collect
then you say you know what can i spend
it on
and they say you have to spend it on
government services
and government services means that you
have to be able to
provide direct service to aid or aid
to citizens like you have to help emily
brock
right now because emily brock is
suffering through the middle of the
pandemic
and because of that because of that
definition
you're also saying we want to make sure
that you don't use it on
past promises or debt that you issued
before now
so don't use the money on debt service
and also they say and this is the most
contentious part of this guidance
they also say don't put it in your rainy
day funds
or your reserves and of course
everyone went bonkers about that because
we used our reserves to get through this
pandemic and that's the whole point here
but what
treasury is arguing is that if you use
this money to deposit into your rainy
day funds or reserves
you're not helping emily brock right now
you're helping future citizens
and so they're saying that is prohibited
as an eligible use in category c
so i think an important distinction
there now
last but not least this was again the
first words and probably the most
the easiest to digest water sewer
infrastructure they did
add in storm water in there as well
so all uh very good things and they were
also very
generous about what does it mean to be
an investment
in and it means building or upgrading
infrastructure it means
engineering scoping it means approaching
a project it means
preparing for a project um now
clearly the the covered period applies
to this period so
uh all of those all of those costs have
to be incurred
by march 3rd 2021 and december
31st 2024 but they can be expended
through
december 31st 2026 so there's a lot of
flexibility built into the water
storm water and sewer infrastructure
section
in the guidance they also are very
specific about broadband infrastructure
and this is where you start to see sort
of
equity components kind of come into the
guidance they're saying
if you do want to invest in broadband
we'd prefer that it'd be owned by the
government
first of all and then second of all that
it's with um that you're investing in
technology for tomorrow you're not
investing in yesterday's technology so
they set
minimum parameters for upload and
download speeds
and that they have to be fiber optic
investments
the other thing to remember broadband
infrastructure is generally a state
venture but there are a lot of
communities that have come together
to create broadband cooperatives so
these two these projects are also being
looked at by local governments which is
i think a great thing
um in uh um
in the guidance they also talk about um
what audit and reconciliation um
these processes need to be put in place
and there's a few things that are of
note
number one there's an interim report
that's due like
right around the corner there's an
interim report due on july 31st 2021
and like is everybody gonna have their
money by then you know like
i mean how are we supposed to do a
report if nobody has their money so
we're still we're still working with
them on that on what type of information
they're going to be reconciling but
the broad categories we can expect them
to be asking new hampshire
what do you intend to be spending this
money on and so there's probably going
to be very broad categories that they're
going to ask for
then of course there's quarterly reports
that are more
um your accounting and auditing typical
accounting and auditing so like
individual payments and grants that
you've sent out from this report so
those are going to be
periodic um pretty constant
probably for all direct recipients and
then
last but not least there's recovery plan
performance reports due from states
and large cities and counties over 250
and what they're going to be asking
there this is when you're going to start
to see
sort of the biden question that they're
going to be asking about
performance indicators based on
objectives and as you read through the
guidance you see things that are
interesting like reference to climate
um reference to equity and social
services
so those might be those performance
indicators that
we'll see in those annual reports that
the
president will be asking for but
nevertheless those are the things that
are
um important for the administration in
terms
of ensuring that they have captured the
legislative intent of the american
rescue plan act so
that's um all i have for you i i know
i've come up to the very last minute but
stop now i
realize there's a couple questions all
right we have two minutes left
and so one question from representative
romney
followed by representing your league
representative real quick last time we
you you presented you said may 10th may
11th
the plans were supposed to be developed
and approved by that point
so is that goal post been moved
officially or what well
uh you mean from the united states
treasury to
to spend it out well indeed so
what the treasury interpreted was that
no no no
what the what the legislative text says
is that you have to
certify those proceeds by may 10th and
so what they did is they opened up that
certification portal
and now they're putting the onus on all
of those jurisdictions to certify the
proceeds
it's up to you i mean if you if you
can't do it by may 10th
or may 17th or where are we today may
19th you should do it sooner than later
i think it's their point but but
everybody didn't have to certify by
may 10th they just had to open up the
portal by may 10th is what their
argument is
represented by representative unions and
representing
representative on broadband the question
is
since most of the communities in new
hampshire
uh contract with entities is
is that government or how does that work
i mean
we just don't have town operations for
broadband nor should the town actually
they are not definitive on operations on
whether it should be operated by private
corporations or if it's publicly
operated fiber optic
so i think they well they said they
would really like for it to be a
government
enterprise you can read in the guidance
that it's that they realize they can't
they can't um make that a requirement of
this
specific investment because of the way
that fiber optic
fiber optic broadband delivery works i
mean there's the initial mile the middle
mile and the last mile right and so
there's a lot of corporations that are
involved in that process so
um i think that they realize they
couldn't control that
so that the language is more suggestive
than it is
definitive representative followed by
representative spillsbury
thank you mr chairman and thank you ms
brock very quickly
um the the dates for the municipalities
uh if i understood you correctly that's
not all exactly
ironed out yet for the municipalities
and how they have to report this
can you just clarify that for me just a
little bit because i know that my town
administrator is going to ask me because
he's watching
so um in terms of timing for what for
reporting
okay right so in terms of reporting
so there's no guideline or timeline on
certification but the sooner the better
obviously
in terms of reporting the information
there will be
there will be an initial report due on
july 31st
2021 so that will be the initial report
that's due
but as you certify you'll start to see
that they will develop these quarterly
reporting schedules and the quarterly
reporting
schedules will start may 10th and we'll
start to see
quarterly reports due um from direct
recipients
at basically at quarterly times from the
united states
office of the inspector general so oig
will be issuing out those
intervals and we'll be making sure to
keep those in bright lines because those
are things that are important to gfy
members as well
representative spellsbury thank you
our county is due to receive about eight
million dollars we understand
uh coincidentally we're considering a 54
million dollar
uh project to renovate and expand
the county nursing home that of course
is not broadband water or sewer
uh how much freedom is there on other
infrastructure projects
um is so in eligible use category a if
the expansion can be drawn
back to um the mitigating the effects of
kovic 19 in your economy
then infrastructure falls underneath
there in fact they actually use the
words
um going back to my slides they use the
capital investments in public facilities
to meet
pandemic operational needs etc so
what that would mean from a nursing
facility perspective that falls
fairly well into there and we've
received a lot of questions from
counties
that are that are really thinking about
health care capital investments
healthcare infrastructure and
and eligible use category a allows for
them to sort of capture that
so if it's an eight million dollars and
it's a 54 million dollar project
then obviously a portion of it could be
cash financed or
pay go and then the rest of it could be
bonded so i think
great flexibility and eligible use
category a for that for that
emily i do have to jump i do have to
jump but
it's it's been a real pleasure and i'm
i'm also very happy to answer questions
by email
um and i will stick my email in the chat
if you do have more specific questions
or
if your administrators of your various
local governments have questions as well
i'm certainly happy to provide these
slides to them as well
can you provide us a copy of the slides
and provide us also in your email
for sure welcome thank you very much for
taking the time
thank you appreciate it thank you
all right committee i think that's been
a very fruitful morning
i've scheduled next week tuesday
wednesday and thursday in case we
need them for revenue estimates
on tuesday we'd like to be able to
find the exact senate bill 3.
we'll start off with a work session and
then hopefully
we can proceed into a uh executive
session
because we we've run out of time
any uh further questions or comments
representative nunes uh yes thank you mr
chairman
uh will miss brock be coming back to
visit with us again
uh as more of these rules roll out and
more information is given i think that
what we see here this big
broad overview we're trying to
understand it all
it is a lot we do have town
administrators and county administrators
that want to speak with all of us about
this
uh they're very interested in when
they're going to get the funds
and how they can spend it and what how
they have to report it and
i i'm sure many of you are working with
your towns just like i am
to try to hold their hand through the
process
i think that the more information we can
get as soon as it comes out the better
we'll be
in helping our town administrators
figure out how they need to get all this
stuff certified and reported to the
government
i agree with you numerous
and just as soon as enough
new information comes out we'll have her
back
and it's easy because of zoom as you
as you heard she was pulled away from 11
o'clock made to meet the treasurer
at 11 and then was able to meet with us
at 12
now she's on to another meeting
okay anything else hopefully she gets
some lunch in between
yes all right then
uh i have nothing else for today
uh think about what you've heard
and if if you have any amendments on
senate bill 3
or if anything you want to share
prior to that then maybe we could do it